five months after briana taylor's death
in kentucky her family is still waiting
for answers
taylor was shot and killed in her
apartment by louisville police while she
was sleeping
no one has been charged this week
taylor's family met with the state's
attorney general
who is leading the investigation our
national correspondent jerica duncan
spoke with them
and their attorney 150 days
five months
yeah every day is still march the 13th
for the first time since her daughter's
death briana taylor's mother tamika
palmer met with kentucky attorney
general daniel cameron
there definitely shouldn't be another
brianna taylor we spoke to the family's
attorney ben crump
is it fair to characterize how she feels
as better
after having this 40 minute conversation
with the attorney general
yes i think so she is cautiously
optimistic
until it happens attorney general
cameron said he called the meeting to
express his condolences
but did not provide any new information
all along cameron has said he will not
give a timeline on the investigation
taylor's sister janayah palmer what is
that like for you
it just feels like i'm working for my
sister
it feels like i'm working to make sure
her name doesn't die
and to make sure justice does get served
across the nation supporters have joined
that cry for justice
[Applause]
taylor a 26 year old emt was shot and
killed in her own home by police
in march the officers had a no knock
warrant because they suspected drug
activity at taylor's apartment
but no drugs were ever found in june one
of the officers involved
detective brett hankinson was fired two
others were put on administrative leave
are you confident that all three
officers will be charged
i don't know how many officers will be
charged
but i know that somebody needs to be
charged and held accountable the
kentucky attorney general released a
statement after meeting with briana
taylor's family
saying that the investigation is ongoing
earlier this month he said he was still
awaiting ballistic reports
from the fbi michelle this is a
story that just won't go away because
people aren't going to let it
folks are still protesting and they want
some action jerica thank you so much